in west yorkshire if you commit the
crime you should be prepared for another
level of exposure the police website
tells you who's been up to what and how
they were punished neighborhood crime
maps already show the number of offenses
committed in an area the government
would like to see this pilot scheme
expanded the idea is supposed to show
residents that criminals are being
caught while also serving as a deterrent
the policing in criminal justice
minister nick herbert has backed the
plans as the next step when internet
crime maps were first launched in
january the police website proved so
popular it crashed since then it's been
visited 420 million times is popular but
critics say it's imperfect I think it's
got a real smell of a gimmick about at
this I mean what are you supposed to do
memorize all the names and pictures and
then look out for them at the bus stop I
also worry that it could encourage
vigilantes naming and shaming criminals
is likely to anger civil liberties
campaigners but appearing tough on
criminals is crucial for the
Conservatives who have seen their
reputation on law and order slip in
recent months we animals Sky News